well well buddy
participating and now without further
ado we're gonna move into the second
phase
and I'd like to introduce our first
speaker dr. David Handley works for the
University of Maine at the high Mora
research farm he is responsible for
vegetable and small variety evaluations
and integrated pest management
strategies
and he's been a cooperator on this
project and i really appreciate having
him here he's going to speak to us about
cultural control options for bramble
weed management
Hanley Thank You Laura
well good afternoon I'm gonna cover the
basics of weed management without
chemicals we're going to of course
discuss chemicals as part of the options
as we go along but rich banana we'll get
into those specifically a little bit
later on so to start off and just to
introduce the topic we need to
understand exactly what a weed is and
what it's doing and how we're going to
manage it based on that a weed is
basically a plant that's in the wrong
place at the wrong time from your
perspective this means that it's going
to compete with those plants for light
nutrients and water given that
definition raspberries can actually
become their own worst wheat if you're
not doing a good job pruning them and
keeping the plant population down for
they too will compete amongst themselves
for light nutrients and water
raspberries create kind of a special
case for weed management if you're used
to growing other crops like vegetables
for example that can make it a little
more challenging to get weeds under
control and keep them under control
for one thing they're perennial and this
eliminates the opportunity for crop
rotation in other words you can't say
well was a bad meteor this year I'm just
going to rotate out and do something
different next year hopefully that
plantings going to be with you for 10 or
20 years
in addition raspberries are shallow
rooted and this means that they're not
really suited to close cultivation
because any equipment you have in there
disturbing the top layer of the soil is
going to harm the roots of the raspberry
plant and also because they're shallow
rooted they tend to be very poor
competitors with weeds if you can
imagine a grass for example in a
raspberry planting their roots are in
the exact same spot because over 70% of
a raspberries root system is in the top
eight inches of the soil this is also an
issue with just about any perennial weed
that's going to be in there directly
competing with them raspberries are also
herbicide sensitive especially younger
plantings so the use of herbicides has
to be carefully monitored there are only
a few chemicals out there that will
control weeds without actually harming
the raspberry plants and Richard will
talk about this later
so your options are fairly limited in
that
so one of the keys of having a
successful weed management program in
raspberries is to make sure that you get
off on the right foot and what we're
talking about here is pre-plant me
control
this is really the cornerstone of a
successful weed management program and
this should begin anywhere for one to
three years before you plant a single
raspberry in the ground depending on
what
condition the site is in when you get
started and when we talk about what are
we the types of things that need to go
into pre plant management we're talking
about looking at site selection what
amendments you're going to add to that
soil and how that's going to impact weed
leads in the future if you're going to
use cover crops what cover crops you're
going to use and how but sort of
strategies you're going to use with them
the possibility of following before
planting in other words keeping that
soil bare for a year or two to try to
deplete the weed seed population and
then as we get ready to plant using some
techniques to keep the weeds down in
that planting here such as stale seed
beds or strip tillage and it will cover
each of these in a little more detail so
looking at site selection specifically
one of the things you want to do when
you decide you're going to plant
raspberries and where you're going to
plant raspberries is to take a look at
that site and determine what's happened
there previously with an eye toward
weeds management for example with
previous crops have you had there it's
going to be a big difference whether
this was a well tilled and well managed
vegetable planting as opposed to a
neglected pasture for the last 20 years
in terms of what types of weeds you're
going to be facing and then looking at
that ground what sort of weed history do
you know there's a particular perennial
weed that's been a problem quackgrass or
not sedge for example that is going to
cause a special issue for you if you're
trying to plant a perennial crop like
raspberries in there and then also take
a look at the weed management history
again if this has been a cornfield or
something where herbicides have been
used in the past try to get an idea of
what chemicals have been used and how
recently they've been used and whether
or not there's any plant back
restrictions that might cause a problem
with the plants themselves so not only
weeds but the potential for herbicide
residue could be an issue
you want to take a close look at that
site for what existing weed species
there are not only annual weeds would
she might be relatively easy to control
but especially perennial species that
might be in there that need to be
controlled before we start planting and
you can develop a strategy to get them
out of there before those plants go on
the ground pay special attention to
whether or not there's wild brambles in
there for the not only the reason that
these can be a challenging weed to get
rid of but they act as disease hosts
especially viruses and wild brambles
really need to be controlled before you
put any of your cultivated varieties in
there
what soil amendments are you going to
use we often add soil amendments to try
to build soil organic matter and improve
the nutrient holding capacity of the
soil and soil drainage but if we use
animal manures these can often contain
we've seen horse manure is popular in my
area and unfortunately horses are very
poor at processing weed seed and as a
result unless the animal manure has been
composted you can be spreading millions
and millions of wee seeds on your ground
as you think you're helping it by trying
to get some organic matter built up one
of the ways you can get around this is
to try to compost any manures that you
have compost however also can contain
wheat seed unless it's properly done it
should be finished in other words that
compost should have been warmed up to at
least 140 preferably 150 degrees to kill
most of the weed seeds that's in there
and regularly turn to make sure that
there's a uniform product throughout the
other thing I hate to see is people
saying they're going to put compost on
and you walk over the compost pile and
you can see knee-high weeds growing on
the pile because it's been sitting there
for several months so if you're not
going to be able to use the compost
right away you should either turn it
regularly or cover it to make sure that
weed seeds aren't blown on and start to
get established and then drop their own
seed in
and cause problems in the future
as we move into site preparation one of
the things you may be considering is
cover crops now cover crops are
typically added to build soil organic
matter but they're also promoted as a
strategy to reduce wheat seeds in there
while they do improve soil structure
whether or not they reduce weed pressure
is really up to you and how you manage
those cover crops just saying you're
putting a cover crop on there doesn't
mean you're gonna get good weed control
although cover crops can shade out some
species some may survive quite well
beneath the canopy you just can't see
them they are and indeed they're
shedding seeds and adding to the wheat
seed bank instead of depleting it as you
would like them to do so overall and
discussions with rich banana will you'll
be hearing from later we feel that
unless they're managed very well cover
crops can actually have little wheat a
little impact on the total weed seed
population if we use short term cover
crops in other words two three or maybe
even four crops over a summer and
combine these with repeated tillage
you're much more likely to get some
impact on the weed seatback over time
the other strategy you can use is to let
cover crops that have some allele
Pathak's of characteristics such as rye
or soot acts and these can give off root
exudates or chemicals within the roots
that actually inhibit weed seed
germination if you're interested in that
I'd suggest you look at some of the
literature that's out there on a little
Pathak species and determine whether or
not this is something that's actually
going to work for you and your in the
particular situation that you're in
here are some of the cover crop options
I don't want to spend a lot of time on
this you can go back to this later but
these are some of the more popular crops
looking at things like buckwheat for
example it's very easy to grow and
actually has very good weed suppression
the problem with buckwheat is doesn't
offer you very much in the way of
organic matter
and if you allow it to go to seed before
you get it down it itself will actually
become one of your worst wheat headaches
oats are also a very popular one the
nice thing about oats is that they
winter kill so you don't have to worry
about trying to kill them and having
them come back on you but they don't
tend to do a particularly good job at
choking out weeds unless you see them
very thick Dutch white clovers not when
I'm a big fan of but people like it
because it's a legume and can add some
nitrogen to the soil but you find over
time it's a little difficult to
establish so that weeds can come up and
kind of get in there and see before the
white clover actually becomes
well-established also Dutch white clover
itself can become a weed issue in
raspberries as is one of the plants that
will happily grow through a mulch red
clover is one I would suggest if you
have a hard pan situation because it's
very deep-rooted and can crack and break
open some hard pans but it really takes
two seasons to get established annual
ryegrass don't let the name fool you
this one will act as a perennial in some
situations but it's one that people are
starting to look at as a good miner of
soil bringing soils back up to the
surface and then we incorporate
winter eye is one that gives very good
cover and offers a pretty good shading
and choking out of weed species but it
is winter hardy and it will have to be
killed either by tilling or using
herbicides in the springtime and then
finally sorghum Sudan is another one
that has some allelopathy qualities this
one produces a lot of vegetative growth
and you might need special equipment
just to plow it down just taking a look
at a slide here you can see the top
slide is winter rye even a good standard
winter rye unless you've got a good
mower is going to be difficult to put
down in the springtime as I said this
one will overwinter and will go to seed
and you need to mow it down
before that scene matures on the bottom
slide you see sorghum Sudan again this
isn't something you're going to do with
a hand mower or a weed whacker you need
to have good equipment to push lock to
be able to get this down but you can
just see the amount of organic matter
you're working into the soil and the
potential for choking out weeds there
now let's move into getting actually
ready for planting these after we've
hopefully overcome most of the more
serious weed problems we can get ready
to plant these and we want to plant them
in such a way that we're not actually
encouraging more weed growth one of the
ways to do this as we approach the
planting years to maybe fallow it for
the season before planting and this is
just a case of using repeated tillage
throughout the growing season not
allowing anything to grow on that soil
for an entire season this is a very good
way of depleting the annual seed bank
because you till you bring up more weed
seeds they germinate you till again
before they go to seed you keep bringing
up more weed seeds and killing them out
before they have a chance to reproduce
you can also get a head of perennial
weeds such as quack grass this way by
continually bringing up the root system
dehydrating them not allowing them to
get ahead of them and basically depite
depleting those plant reserves in there
the problems with fallowing is that it's
somewhat energy intensive it can be a
little hard on the soil structure
because you're not really adding organic
matter to that and you're regularly
stirring up the soil breaking up some of
those clods but if you have a lot of
organic matter in the soil this
shouldn't be too big an issue doing this
for one season erosion of course is a
problem if you're on a slope for example
and water is going to pull your soil off
or if you're in a particularly windy
area you'd be surprised how much soil it
can actually
but fallowing is a strategy that can
work fairly well for getting rid of some
nasty lead problems without having to
use chemicals
as we're getting ready
plant there are some other strategies we
can use stale seed bed is one that's
popular with vegetable growers but could
also be used for the Ferengi across such
as strawberries or raspberries in this
case we prepare the ground either in the
follow of the early spring all set nice
and tidy ready for planting but in the
spring we allow that soil to sit and
weed seed starts to germinate I have two
to four weeks here is probably more
likely four to six weeks that you allow
those those weeds to start coming up but
not to the point where they're going to
be flowering or setting C then we killed
it those weeds back either with a
contact herbicide or flame and we don't
disturb the soil surface in other words
we're not cultivating here we're just
killing out what's on top if we don't
destroy disturb the soil surface we're
gonna prevent new weed seeds from
surfacing and basically keep that soft
layer of soil acting somewhat as a mulch
then we plant keeping the soil
disturbance to a minimum so just plant
right in the plant rows the area between
your rows which in the case of
raspberries is a good 8 to 12 feet a
good bit of soil surface there
undisturbed and that should keep your
weeds under control anywhere from a few
days to weeks depending on how much rain
you get anything else that might disturb
the soil surface and how much of a weed
seed bank you have but still seed beds
can't be a good way of getting your
plants off to a good start give you a
few days to a few weeks of relatively
weed free conditions this is not going
to be true of where you've disturbed the
soil every place you've dug a little
hole or dug a trench to put those plants
and you're going to see weeds starting
to come up so you will have to have some
other strategy for that such as hand
poling
strip tillage is another thing that's
being looked at again we're seeing a lot
of this being used in vegetable crops
but there's no reason it couldn't work
with perennial crops such as raspberries
or strawberries in this case again we
prepared
the ground in the early fall and in this
case we see the cover crop the most
popular one is winter rye but we can
also use annual rye or oats now this
crop will grow up during the late summer
and fall of that previous year then in
the springtime we go through and kill
that cover crop now in the case of oats
they winter kill so we don't have to
worry about it but in the case of the
annual rye of the winter rye we would
probably have to use a post emergent
contact herbicide remark so it is
typically used but there might be
something like paraquad as well and rich
can speak to this a little bit later
then without just without barely
disturbing that plant residue we leave
the residue there to act as a mulch we
tilled narrow strips through the dead
cover this does require specialized
equipment I'll show you a picture of
that in a minute
and then we just plant the raspberries
right into these strips the dead
vegetation inhibits wheat growth it also
tends to keep the soil kind of cold so
you may see that this delays a little
bit the emergence of new primer canes
and root growth in your plants but
raspberries are pretty tolerant of cold
temps cold soil temperature so I don't
think this would be too big a deal
here's a picture of a stripped tiller
going through in this case it was also a
fertilizer injector on the back of it
but what we see here is that there's
just a series of deep tillage blades
here some blades that go down deep and
then a couple of little kultur blades
that just roll behind and bring that
stir that soil surface up to make a
decent planting strip and we can see the
strips here in this case of course those
strips are far closer than we'd have
them in a raspberry situation but you
get the idea so this works fairly well
and again that residues going to hang
around in the case of rye would hang
around probably through most of the
planting season in the case of oats
you'll probably find that residue will
break down by about halfway through the
season
now as we move into the planting year
itself it's important to understand that
we really want no competition plant
competition for the raspberries in that
planting one of the things I hate to see
is going into a an established turf and
then carving out some narrow rows with a
rototiller and then planting our
raspberries into that frequently those
turf species are fairly aggressive and
will move back in and become the
predominant plant right over your
raspberries so I really prefer to see
that there be no competition in the
planting year between the rows now we
can keep that area between the rows
clean with shallow cultivation or with
flaming there are good flame leaders out
there it will have to be directed so
that the flames aren't going to burn the
raspberry plants you've put in there so
they'll have to be some shielding
involved and within the rows we can
either use hand pulling and that won't
be too big a job if we've done a good
job of pre plant weed management or with
there are some detailed cultivators out
there that will do a reasonably good job
between the plants they won't get you
completely out of hand weeding but they
will help here's some of those
cultivators just taking a look at them
this is a budding cultivator that you
see here what you see is the plant
actually runs through this series of
wheels with fingers on it that means
that these can get quite close and these
little times the top inch or two of the
soil keeping those weeds down
of course the tool bar you can see here
is set fairly low so this is only going
to work well if you're using plug plans
for your raspberries but also if you use
dormant canes as long as you cut the
handle off you could be able to get a
couple of good weeks of use out of this
the regi leader that you see here is
very similar in that we have two
spinning heads with fingers on them down
here that will get rid of a lot of the
weeds and we have handles up here that
we can bring in or out and make those
heads go
closer or further away as we approach
the plans this also works fairly well
again you see we have a little more
clearance here so we'll probably be able
to use this throughout I would guess
most of the planting here but they'll
still be some hand weeding to do in
terms of using cultivators between the
rows and in the aisle ways we can just
use a broad cultivator this is a laylee
tying cultivator does a pretty good job
of just disturbing the top inch or so of
the soil does a very good job of keeping
the weeds down provided that you're
using this before the weeds actually
break the soil surface we call this
blind cultivation you want to get these
weeds under control there's still and
what we call the white thread stage
before they've actually emerged from the
ground so this has to happen about every
10 to 14 days depending on how much
moisture you're getting just going
through there and raking this over the
plants and here we see a flame leader
there's many different sorts of this but
many heads on this this could go between
the rows with some propane tanks in the
back leading to this and it's ignited
and the flames just go over and burn
them out again you don't have to toast
the the whole weeds with a flame you
just need to go over them very quickly
and the cells will basically explode and
kill those plans
well what about mulch actually between
the rows using that space between the
rows and covering it up with mulch if we
don't want to cultivate well if we're
using strip chillage the residue is
already there acting as a mulch so that
will help you could apply straw between
the rows but it's going to be fairly
expensive I would not recommend using
mulch a because this is loaded with weed
seeds and you'll have a lovely hay crop
coming up in your raspberries the next
year landscape fabric can also be used
but it's very expensive and it's hard to
maintain because dust and dirt will be
dragged on there by your equipment so
forth and any place that happens
that you're gonna have means starting to
grow through it it's also extremely
costly the only place I've seen
landscape fabric used any effect is
under high tunnels I don't think it
really has a place out of the field and
as I said the cost is very high in the
maintenance can be also quite high but
it is a strategy you can use if you're
only using a small planting to mulch
between the rows I've also heard people
say that they'd like to try to get some
row crops between there such as beans or
one of these other vegetable crops these
these can be used again as long as
you're keeping them far enough away and
you don't feel that they're going to be
competitive with the raspberries
themselves well what about within the
row within the row mulch is also an
option straw can be used this has
actually been shown to be very helpful
especially around plug plants however I
say this with an important caveat the
straw does need to be removed in the
fall so we can put it over the plants
right after planting in the spring but
we do need to remove it in the fall the
reason for this is that through the
winter and in the early following spring
what'll happen is it keeps us all very
cold and wet and tends to make the
plants very susceptible to fight off
their Marvin fritz did a nice study on
this a few years back so what I would
recommend is go ahead and use straw
around the plants to try to keep weeds
from around growing right around the
plants if you will but remember to take
it off because you want that soil to dry
out as quickly as possible in the spring
using raised beds can also help you in
this situation
wood chips and shavings can also be used
they're a little bit heavy for using in
the planting year and they will delay
the emergence of the primer canes but if
you feel that you've got a long growing
season ahead of you and you've got nice
vigorous plants a light application of
wood chips or shavings could be helpful
I'm not a big fan of sadhus sadhus tends
to be have too fine a particulate in it
it tends to crusts and as a result of
that you'll find that the water has a
very doesn't
not penetrate very well from sawdust in
fact it'll bounce right off in water the
weeds on the sides so what I would
recommend is if you could use sawdust
blend it with some wood chips or
shavings or try to help that way if
you've got a source of good clean
compost this can be used as a mulch it
you can see that in the lower slide here
I've tried this myself and we got very
good weed control throughout most of the
first growing season a problem with
compost of course is it's actually a
pretty good media for plants to grow on
so if you have a lot of have a lot of
weed seeds blowing in it can result in
some problems for you but if the mulch
it so if the compost itself is quite
clean and you don't have a lot of wheat
seeds blowing in this can actually
provide a good surface cover cover up
any weed seeds that are in the soil and
also over time as it's breaking down
provide nutrients for those growing
plants I often get questions about using
pine needles or leaves or these sorts of
things usually if we've got a big
planting the issue here is with supply
cost it's really worth your time to go
and rake all those things out pine
needles are a great mulch they'll work
terrific but the question is whether or
not he can get enough of them
leaves I'm not so fond of unless they've
been broken up because they tend to get
matte down around the plant keep it wet
and can lead to fight off the problems
as opposed to pine yields which I was
just going to talk about
and Emily yeah I'm approaching plastic
knowledge folks I'm not forgetting
leaving the mulch in place if you're
planting out ridges or raised beds
with straw I would say no the evidence
is pretty clear that straw mulch just is
really bad as far as far as by Toffler
is concerned if you're using something
that's more porous and allows air
through it so that it will warm up more
quickly such as the shavings that we
talked about I would say okay
okay but straw mulch in my opinion is
fine for the planting year but even with
raised beds I would be inclined to take
it off the year after that unless of
course you feel it's broken down if it's
degraded enough that it's not really
going to be causing you any issues in
that case you could probably leave it on
well what about plastic we get this
question a lot about using plastic mulch
first and foremost it's a little bit
expensive you're looking at something in
between anywhere depending on what types
of plastic you use six hundred to a
thousand dollars an acre I precise
should pull that back it would be a
little bit less than that because you're
using you're not using quite as much in
a raspberry planting it really depends
on what sort of plastic you're using and
how long you want that plastic to last
what we have found with shallow rooted
perennial plants like raspberries and
blueberries that we do get a little
inhibition of roots right near the
surface of the soil and we think this is
because the temperature gradient under
the mulch is a little bit different than
it would be under bare soil but overall
it doesn't seem to have a huge impact on
plant growth it will inhibit provoking
growth if you just lay black plastic out
there punch some holes in it and plant
through those holes remember that your
new primal canes are going to be coming
up from root buds further away from
those initially planted crowns so after
those plants have been in for a couple
of weeks you will need to run a slit
down the middle or maybe cut out a strip
about a foot a foot and a half wide to
allow those new primal canes to come up
or else you're not going to get good
plant growth from there now the
biodegradable mulch may offer a good
answer here and that you can put these
mulches down and then they will start to
degrade the problem with these so far is
that they're usually designed to last
perhaps a little bit longer than we'd
want them to in order to get those prime
Akane's up and growing earlier so you'd
want to take a look at the biodegradable
mulches are usually rated on how long
they will last before they start to
degrade and you may want to go with one
that will start to degrade relatively
early bear in mind that they're going to
degrade all the way they aren't going to
give you protection on the edges like
you've seen with a more permanent mulch
as you see in this picture this is
actually under a high tunnel in
California and the biodegradable types
are more expensive right now there's
somewhere between two or three times the
cost of the regular black plastic
normative but flat plastic can be used
just bear in mind that you've got to
make room for those primal canes to come
up and that's going to be a little
pricey but it may be a cheap way out if
you consider how much it cost you to go
through there and do a meeting okay
now let's move into actually the years
after planting as we move into years two
three four and five as we're getting
this planting established there are some
options for weed control as we move
through here one of the options is to
keep this clean cultivated this is the
way that a lot of the growers handle
this in the larger raspberry growing
regions of the country where the crop is
mostly harvested for processing how can
we keep those weeds down in the areas
but both in the Iowas and in the row
well frequent light tillage as we've
already talked about in the planting
year using flamers is another way to do
it again it have to be directed so that
we're not burning the plants the
raspberry plants themselves and pulling
practical in the row I don't think it's
very practical but in the aisle ways
there and of course just the idea of
clean cultivation here is fairly going
to be energy intensive it's going to be
difficult with perennials especially if
you've got one that snuck in there or
was already established in there before
you got planted erosion is going to be a
problem for you here again if you're on
a slope or susceptible to it and dust
can also be an issue if you're
cultivating in there when the fruit or
ripe you're going to have some dust
issues on there the other issue we have
with dust if you're planting is quite
dusty it tends to be a real attraction
for - spotted spider mites so something
else to keep in mind but a possibility
if you think you've got you
equipment in time to manage this another
way of going at this is looking at using
clean cultivation in the summer but then
planting a fall cover crop so as we
talked about in the previous slide
during the summer time we'd use frequent
light tillage to keep the weeds out then
we would see the crop of oats in the
late summer or early fall about the time
we're finishing up harvest of our summer
our floor cane bearing varieties the
oats will winter kill
and then the residue acts as a mulch in
the spring similar to what we talked
about with strip tillage summer tillage
is still going to be needed because the
oat residue will probably break down and
weeds will start to grow through it
before the end of the season so you'll
probably find you have to till one or
two times before you could resi the oats
next year bear in mind if you're going
to grow old you are going to have to put
some fertilizer down there for them in
order to get them established you can't
just keep planting them and expect them
to do well this might not be practical
for Primal cutting fruiting varieties
because you're going to be seeing those
oats that having it come up about the
same time that you need to be in there
doing harvesting and other operations so
you may not be able to establish a good
cover crop in there with the propagating
fooders but this is something to be
looked at dr. prince has done quite a
bit of work with this and strawberries
and found it that it can work very well
there I don't see any reason why we
couldn't expand that into raspberry
production as well
but what is most commonly done here in
the Northeast is using a living mulch
between the rows and this is just a turf
grass established in those aisle ways
but not allowed to get into the plant
rows themselves so we leave about a
three to five foot strip bare strip in
the plant rows so you point that out
here so this area here has no grass
growing in it or so we hope
and then the aisle ways themselves have
a perennial grass species growing
now I don't want to see this put in
prior to the plant going and as I said I
don't want any competition in the
planting here so generally what I
recommend is that this be sown in the in
August or September of the planting year
or sewn in this following spring
generally what we want to see used here
is a weak perennial grass species such
as a non creeping hard fescue or
perennial rye or a mix of those two
these are slow growing they tend to be
slow to establish so we have to be
patient with them and we may have to
control weeds coming up through them but
if they have enough nitrogen eventually
they will cover the crop pretty well and
be able to help compete most of the
weeds that are coming in we don't want
to use a conservation mix or a
contractor's mix or a pasture mix
because these contain very aggressive
rosanna miss grass species that will
quickly become your worst feed problem I
also don't really care to use clover I
know it does add nitrogen to the soil
but clover can also become a weed
problem it will grow through mulch so it
is difficult that way and it can also
carry some diseases that they will share
with raspberries such as verticillium
and tomato ringspot virus
believe me clover is going to come in on
its own I don't panic too much about
trying to control it but I certainly
don't like seeding it in there now once
we have this established it should be
mowed regularly to make sure that any
weeds that are in amongst that grass is
not allowed to grow up in shed seed so
if we keep this grass mowed quite tight
the grass will survive and the weeds
will eventually be depleted
as we move on to just looking at this
here we are seeing a crop that's been
seated in the establishment year you can
see here
there I've got grass just starting to
come up I've mulch between the rows this
is a little heavy for what I'd like to
see in the planting here but the heads
doing fairly well please note the
trickle irrigation line that's an awful
nice thing to have and raspberries
really helps them go as we move into the
spring of the second year in this slide
again you can see the grass getting
well-established you can see that nice
interface between the grass and the
mulch the grass is not encroaching in of
course you can see the clover has come
in on its own
and then what about mulch in the rows
within the rows again just like we
talked about the planting your wood
chips and shavings once those plants are
established a good thick layer will do a
pretty good job we don't want don't want
to use an old pile that has lots of
wheat seed in it but a good fresh pile
of wood chips will help this should be
four to eight inches thick we can add to
this as needed because it will break
down over time and yes mulch does have
some impact on fertility it will deplete
the soil of the nitrogen right at the
soil surface and it can drop your pH but
this can easily be compensated for by
having a soil test see what you need to
add for fertilizer see what you need to
occasionally add for lime over the top
and you can compensate for any impact on
the soil fertility that this mulch might
be having and overall this is probably
the best way to control weeds in the
planting during those early years of
establishment and then as we look at the
annual maintenance of this as we finish
up here we keep our grass aisles mowed
tight as I said to prevent any weeds
from starting to come up and germinate
that don't over fertilize those aisles
we do need a little nitrogen to keep
that grass growing and to prevent other
weeds from coming in but if you over
fertilize them they will become more
aggressive and try to get into that plan
again you're gonna have to mow more you
need to control it encroachment those
grasses will try to move in on the
raspberry borders and you can do this
either with
herbicide strips are with shielded
flamers or just with an edging tool for
the grass now this will hurt the
raspberry roots a bit but if you're out
far enough it shouldn't have a big
impact on we need to replenish the mulch
occasionally just take a look at it each
fall in spring see if you need to add
another inch next year but over time
you'll find as these raspberries come
thick and established as you see in this
light they do a pretty good job of
shading out most of the weeds that are
coming in there and you may find that
you can allow that mulch to get depleted
fairly well and then it won't be have
that cooling effect on the soil that
delays emergence of the primer canes in
the spring don't be fooled some hand
weeding is still going to be necessary
and it's important to keep the area
around your planting mode as well
because if you're busy mowing in here
and keeping the weed seeds down but
they're blowing in from the unmowed area
around your raspberries you're still
going to have weed problems
so in summary with our non-chemical weed
control bear in mind that the average
bed life of a raspberry plant is 10 to
15 years however I've been in plantings
that are 2025 years old the most common
reason for early bed failure in
raspberries is weeds period we talk
about insects we talk about diseases but
weeds are really the reason that of
raspberry planting becomes non viable
economically your pass to success for
making sure that your raspberries are
not going to fall victim to weeds good
free plant preparation as we talked
about regular cultivation
using mulch in the rows can help hand
pulling is going to be necessary and of
course vigilance keeping an eye on the
weed situation as it develops don't
allow any particular weed species to get
ahead of you walk through that planting
if something is starting to develop
control it before it becomes up
throughout your planting I just point
out this this last slide here
I always find it amusing to be in a
raspberry planting like this where the
weeds are up to my chest but the growers
diligently put a Japanese beetle trap on
the end of the row believe me his
problem is not Japanese beetles at this
point he's losing a lot more money to
those weeds than anything the beetles
are doing and with that I think or do
you want me to take questions now or
he'll still be there at the end of dr
benardos so if you think of it then you
can ask
but just type your question into the
chat box
we're waiting for people to do that
you change
isn't a shin here
I hope I answered your questions about
the degradable mouse I don't know of
anyone who's actually been working with
degradable mulch other than a few
growers who have been trying it I do
think it holds a lot of promise for
raspberries and my suggestion at this
point is if you're interested in the
plastic mulch is you can find a source
at a reasonable price give it a try it
looks it looks promising to me my only
worry is again that it won't degrade in
time to allow you should easily come up
in regards to the raised ridges I do I
do like raspberries being planted on
raised beds I think it's an ideal
situation for raspberries because it
really helps define that where the
raspberries and in your aisle way should
begin and that is very helpful as part
of your weed management plan and it also
will help with things like bite off tour
but just be aware that straw mulch can
be if a thick straw mulch layer is on
there in the spring time it's keeping
those roots wet it's keeping those roots
cold even on raised beds it could be an
issue if you're in an area like there's
a problem we tried the biodegradable
mulch with a few growers and had very
mixed results
you know they were very encouraged by it
and then we had other
interesting oh there is one question
about the best time to put mulch
in the planting year in my opinion if
you're using straw you can put it on
right away it's so light and fluffy that
it will provide some weed control if
you're going with a heavier mulch like
the woodchips I would probably wait
until your primer canes have started to
emerge because if you put it on real
thick right off the bat you're going to
delay that primal kenan birkan
so I probably be putting it on mid
summer time as we're moving toward the
fall and until that time
dr. rich Bonanno who is the weed
management specialist for vegetable and
fruit crops at the University of
Massachusetts
rich if you are right there I'll have
you come on and you can just take it
from here
we can thank you I am here can you hear
me okay great hello okay great okay so
I'm here okay so what I'm going to do is
is sort of pick up what David left off
and talk some about how we're besides
fit into this and we'll go through a
number of different slides here
including some slides on different weed
species so bramble floor management
David really talked about two different
areas one is between the rows and also
in the row and what we are looking at is
mostly herbicides being used in the row
between the row is David mentioned
there's always cultivation or some sort
of living mulch how wide of a middle
David mentioned three to five feet and
really what it comes down to is research
has demonstrated that there's always a
benefit from having as much weed free
area or cover crop the area as possible
but there's some sort of practical mix
there where you want to have a weed free
area in the crop row but there's issues
related to traffic ability whether it's
customers walking up and down or whether
it's attractive moving so most people do
have something planted between the crop
burrows some people will plant something
there but if they don't want to mow it
all the time because of energy
constraints you can use low rates of
something like Roundup a very low rate
something like four eight ounces per
acre to go in and kind of hurt the cover
crop and in the winter time excuse me in
the in the spring and it doesn't have a
lot of competition in the summertime you
won't have to mow it very much but it
still is there and it's and it's growing
so why do you want to maintain a weed
free strip in the row david covered a
lot of this but basically it's
competition broadleafs are competitive
grasses are incredibly competitive
because they have a very shallow root
system and and compete most aggressively
with those shallow roots that are there
from the from the bramble planting and
of course weeds Harbor insects diseases
and unwanted animals and
sometimes they can be a little Apothic
effects of weeds even to the bramble
planting so we look at weed species
there's a number of different species
that are going to be out there and they
include summer annual weeds winter
annual weeds biennials and then various
perennials so summer annual weeds are
more of a problem in new plantings
especially when you're going from an
annual culture system maybe vegetables
or even strawberries for that matter
into something like brambles they are
very easy to control though with many of
the residual herbicides and some people
especially in other fruit plantings tree
fruit plantings blueberries are very
into total post emergence controls even
grape growers I've seen people just use
multiple applications of roundup one of
the things that is of benefit when you
are looking at a total post emergence
weed control option is the presence of
bark bark is what allows you to make
multiple applications of roundup and to
not worry a lot about residual
herbicides but with something like
brambles where you're always talking
about these canes coming up nothing is
really ever more than a year or so old
that you never really have bark
developing there's always green tissue
there post emergence only control
practices are not what I recommend
I think residual materials are important
and post emergence should be really to
help clean up problems so some of the
these are some summer annual weeds they
include things that you've commonly seen
common lambsquarters common ragweed also
many summer annual grasses like
crabgrass for example in panic comes and
so forth winter annual weeds can be a
problem for many years into a planting
especially if seed production is allowed
now contrary to summer annual weeds that
germinate in the spring and set their
seeds and drop their seeds in the fall
winter annual weeds germinate in late
summer or early fall grow through the
winter or or basically stay dormant in
the winter time and then produce seeds
the following spring one of the problems
with a lot of winter annual weeds being
out there are any cover for that matter
being out there in the winter
time is the increased potential for
frost damage the cleaner of soil is
under the crop
the more that soil will warm up and the
less impact on that frost damage might
have so just something to keep in mind
in terms of how clean you want that
cover to be under those under that crop
in the winter time and also if you have
a lot of winter annual weeds growing
you're trying to put a residual material
down in the spring a residual herbicide
a lot of that herbicide will be
intercepted by the leaves of that
growing winter annual so it can cause a
problem with getting the herbicides to
work very well so some common winter
annual weeds include chick weed field
pansy hen bit and again all these weeds
usually start to germinate after Labor
Day and they can germinate even through
mid to late October depending on the
season biennials are a different kind of
species they actually live for two full
growing seasons they grow vegetatively
in year one they produce seed in year
two but it's usually a full two year
growing season but they from a practical
standpoint they cause a lot of the same
problems as do winter annuals an example
of a winter annual weed is burdock
excuse me a biennial weed is is burdock
so perennial weeds come in a lot of
different varieties and shapes simple
perennials like dandelions that just
have a taproot creeping perennials which
are usually vining type perennial weeds
that have an underground rhizomes system
and of course grasses common dandelion a
tap root produces reproduces primarily
by seed and does not spread vegetatively
for the most part in in plantings a lot
of vining perennial weeds they reproduce
by rhizomes that grow underneath the
ground and and come up in various places
one of the hardest problems to deal with
with vining perennial weeds like field
bindweed
is that they tend to come up in the
spring and will tend to grow up into the
planting so even if you wanted to say
for example apply roundup in the fall to
control these weeds many times they're
they're up into the planting of the crop
and it's very difficult to make a post
emergence application without also
during the bramble crop quackgrass is an
example of a perennial grass and if I
can remember how to use the pointer here
what's specific about perennials is that
you not only have this these small
fibrous roots which are right close to
the plant but you also have these
rhizomes which is sort of the spaghetti
looking things that are sticking out and
this from these rhizomes that the new
plants can continue to grow one of the
one of the key characteristics of
quackgrass of course is it has these
little Oracle's and it's one way to tell
it from a lot of the other grasses there
- no you really have quackgrass and then
you have a perennial species to deal
with okay so for in row weed management
we're looking at a pre plant and David
covered a lot of that cultural weed
management mulches and so forth David
covered physical weed management
cultivation and hand weeding and and
chemical so we're going to talk a little
bit about chemical and and and about pre
plant as well so just a little bit about
herbicides and selecting the proper
herbicide you should really know what
weed species you have do you have an
annual weed or a perennial weed is it a
grass weed or is it a broadleaf weed the
age of the planting matters if it's a
new planting or it's one that's
established especially with new
plantings and especially if you're using
tissue culture plants you have to be
very careful on what herbicide you might
want to use the first year the older the
planting is the more they're able to
handle herbicide applications soil type
limitations some materials say not to
use them on very sandy soils or very
gravely soils and then also the time of
year is important because most of these
applications will go on in the spring
prior to a lot of growing of the of the
crop okay so to select the proper rate
of a soil applied herbicide whenever
you're applying an herbicide to the soil
to prevent weeds from coming up the rate
of that herbicide is dependent on the
type of soil you have so the more sandy
the soil the lower the rate the heavy of
the soil the higher the rate also it's
based on organic manner less organic
matter equals less of an herbicide rate
a higher
percent organic matter would give you
more of an herbicide rate and this would
be listed on the label so something just
to look for if you're using a post
emergence material something like groom
oxen or roundup or post or fusillade and
we'll get into these materials in a
minute
then it's really what species do you
have and sometimes also the size so more
material might be required to control a
larger weed than a smaller weed okay so
some general guidelines about control
about applying herbicides generally
we're looking at all applications that
are made to the crop road be directed to
the soil or to the weeds at the base of
the Canes and they should avoid green
tissue now if you're using a residual
material a soil applied material it's
usually acceptable that you might hit
the base of the Canes a little bit
you're going on in the spring before you
get a lot of new canes coming up or
really any new canes coming up and you
are going to be usually applying the
material from both sides so you're gonna
be walking down one side of the row
coming back on the other side of the row
so one of the things you want to be
conscious of is overlap you want to make
sure that you're not shooting the
herbicide to the other side as you're
walking down one side and then coming
back and doing the same thing because
right in the center of the row you'll
end up with a double rate so whatever
nozzle setup you use whether it's an
offset nozzle whether it's a single
hundred and ten degree nozzle that puts
out an even rate over the entire amount
of soil that it touches or whether it's
a couple of maybe 80 degree nozzles that
are designed to overlap each other a
little bit just make sure that in the
center of that crop row that you're not
overlapping to the extent that you have
a double rate there okay so here's the
list of herbicides that are registered
in brambles and it's actually quite a
list it's a bigger list than
strawberries but actually quite a
smaller list than would be in
blueberries or even in tree fruits so
I've broken the list into soil apply
materials and also post emergence
materials so soil apply materials on the
left here and they've broken up also
into two categories the first and
materials that are particularly good on
broadleafs but
not particularly good on grasses so they
conclude Catherine princeps simha's een
and sinb are the materials that are very
good on annual grasses will control some
broadleaf weeds but are not as good as
the three materials I just mentioned
they include Sola cam devran arlen
cerflan so you basically have three
materials that are great on broadleafs
three materials that are great on
grasses and in most cases you would use
one of each one from each category
combined usually in the spring and we'll
talk about that in a little bit and that
was what gives you sort of broad
spectrum weed control
Gallery here is a broad leaf material
similar to prints up in simmons een and
CIN bar but it's only registered on new
plantings it's a material that is used
predominantly in nursery production and
doesn't have a lot of presence in in
fruit crops it is not registered for
bearing years but just for non bearing
years so just something to keep in mind
as an alternative really to either
prints up or simha's een or sin bar so
on the other side here we've got post
emergence materials and they're broken
up actually into three categories here
post and fusillade are both post
emergence grass materials they are
designed to control grasses but only
after the grasses are up they've got
good activity on annual grasses but
limited activity on perennial grasses
touchdown and roundup are both post
emergence materials that are
broad-spectrum in other words they'll
control both grasses and broadleaf s--
they will also control annual weeds as
well as perennial weeds so whether it's
a summer annual or a winter annual or a
biennial or perennial regardless if it's
a creeping perennial or a tap root
perennial whether it's a broad leaf or a
grass these materials have excellent
activity touchdown is only registered in
the non bearing year roundup can be used
at any time but also remember these
materials will have activity on the crop
and so small canes coming up or
excessive contact with the foliage and
even contact with the base of the Canes
can be a problem so my recommendation is
that touch down and round up really
should be used for control of perennial
weeds and and probably spot treatment or
individual hand treatment rather than
any sort of broad spraying
on the crop the last three materials
Grimek sown also known as paraquat
scythe which is a material that's made
from sheep fat actually but it's not
armoury approved as far as I can tell
and also rage which is a new material
are all they're all burned down
materials they have they do not
translocate they do not go down to the
root system and kill perennials they
simply burn the tops of the weeds off so
they have some benefit for example if
you wanted to burn off small winter
annuals if you wanted to have a clean
cover under the crop in the winter time
but they will also burn perennial weeds
but they'll only burn the top so in
effect they're the same as mowing
sometimes the use of these products is
called chemical mowing well you can burn
off green foliage green tissue but then
especially in the case of a perennial
it'll it'll just come just come back
rage is the newest of these materials so
I just wanted to have a couple of slides
to tell you about rage common name is
carpenter zone it's a it provides post
emergence control of broadleafs and
grasses all of the three post emergence
contact materials that I mentioned
remark sown and scythe and rage will
control both grasses and broadleaf sore
at least burn all grasses and broadleaf
above the soil line the rate of
carpenter zone or age is 20 to 40 ounces
per acre of the formulated product
usually you'll add either a crop oil
concentrate at 1% which means one gallon
per 100 gallons of spray or a non ionic
surfactant at a quarter of a percent by
volume which would be one quart of
surfactant 400 gallons of spray you
basically would direct this to the base
of the plants before bud break they
suggested hooded or shielded application
after bud break I frankly am always
concerned about any of the
post emergence materials the only
exception would be the grass materials
post a fusillade which will not hurt the
Canes in the case of whether we're
talking about touchdown or roundup or
whether we're talking about any of the
contact materials I still have a little
concern about spraying it and contacting
the Canes at the bottom especially if
there's green tissue and again this is a
contact type material which means that
it will burn green foliage it'll it'll
burn green tissue of any type but will
not translocate the other quick thing I
guess you should keep in mind with any
of the post emergence materials if we're
talking about I see if I can go back to
the list here yep if we're talking about
post a fusillade or touchdown or roundup
these materials all translocate so when
you're talking about how much water you
should use in the application the less
water the better ten gallons of water
per acre will give you much greater
control than 40 gallons of water per
acre using the same rate of the chemical
in this case we're talking about a
material that translocates it goes in
through the foliage a translocation of
the entire plant it not only kills the
above-ground part of the plant but kills
the root system as well and so more
concentrated droplets are the key when
you're talking about a contact material
gramacho scythe or rage the more water
the better because coverage is
everything if you contact every leaf
every leaf will turn brown if you only
contact leaves at the top of the canopy
only leaves at the top of the canopy
will turn brown and you won't get the
control okay one other possible use of
contractors owner rage is to suppress
vegetation between rows that actually
listed on the label so three to four
ounces per acre of this product combined
with crop will concentrate or non-ionic
surfactant using the shielded sprayer
especially if you're doing it after bud
break and that cannot be used even
though you're only putting it in the row
middles here cannot be used within 14
days of harvest ok so again I mentioned
some of these already bramble post
emergence issues there
always new growth there's no real bark
green tissue can be hurt and shielding
is almost a necessity so one of the
things I wanted to mention real quick
and I hope it's on the next slide is
what I call a spot or cut treatment that
really makes sense when we're talking
about some of the perennial weeds and
again let me say that the original list
of materials that I mentioned the soil
residual materials we're really thinking
about those materials controlling summer
annual broadleaf weeds and winter annual
broadleaf weeds but not perennials when
it comes to perennials you need some
other measure of control and that's
really whether roundup where the
touchdown comes in and so I I got a
couple more slides before I talk about
the spot treatment but David mentioned
in some about pre plant if the field was
an annual culture then a cover crop
followed by tillage and David mentioned
this is is really preferred if there's
not a lot of perennial weeds out there
and David talked about cover crops and
also about fallowing but when he talked
about cover crops he talked about
multiple cover crops and that's really
the preferred method I even though yes
leaving a field fallow for the whole
year and just going in with frequent
tillage does a great job of reducing the
weed seed population it's not really the
best thing for the soil so and and this
is very common in organic production
also is to use multiple cover crops the
idea is that if you plan to cover crop
in the spring and you expect at the end
of the season to have fewer weed seeds
then you started at the beginning of the
season you absolutely will not have
fewer weed seeds and I will guarantee
you you'll have more weed seeds the idea
with the multiple cover crops and the
frequent tillage every time the cover
crop gets any real good amount of
biomass is that there's always gonna be
some weed seeds that are gonna germinate
and emerge and grow even with the cover
crop there those weeds weeds will then
produce seed you don't want them to
produce seed the idea is to go in and
disc or provide some tillage rototilling
whatever it is before those new seeds
new weeds produce seeds and by doing it
multiple times maybe every eight weeks
or so
you still get the benefit of having a
cover crop there but you're also doing a
good job of controlling those weeds if
you have a perennial problem out there
maybe there was strawberries there
before maybe there was blueberries or
some other plantings or maybe he pulled
out some apple trees you have a pretty
good chance of having perennial weeds
there you might still want to use a
cover crop early or late but you really
need to attack that perennial weed
problem with roundup in the year before
you plant you do not want to put
yourself into a situation where you're
waiting till the planting year or beyond
to start thinking about controlling
printing of weeds it really should be
done the year prior to planting and the
best time to apply roundup is in the
late summer or fall and the reason is is
that you're not just talking about
burning off what's above-ground you want
to control that underground tap root
that underground rhizomes system and the
only way to do that is to apply that
material at a time of the year when
you're gonna get the translocation going
down to control those weeds and fall is
the time to do it now if it's a
broadleaf species like bindweed for
example or poison ivy or any one of
these other vining materials or even
dandelions late summer early fall when
they're actively growing possibly
producing a reproductive structure like
a flower you can still get good
translocation at that time the danger
with the broad leaves is you don't want
to wait too late because then if you
start having cold weather or a frost you
will not get the translocation grasses
on the other hand can go later in the
season now in the north the the rule of
thumb is we always tell people if you're
going after a perennial grass with
roundup it's not too late if you haven't
sat down for Thanksgiving dinner yet
it's not too late to make the
application because those perennial
grasses especially clack grass or
cheatgrass are still usually green and
actively growing the only criteria would
be is you'd really like to wait for them
to wait for a day where it maybe is
going to get into the high 40s and low
50s so maybe you had a frost at night or
a freeze at night but you're gonna have
a fairly warm day the middle of that day
would be the best time to make that
application so we really look at sort of
a common
weed management strategy using
herbicides in in brambles we're thinking
about using prints up or sin bar for
broadleaf weeds as a residual material
we're looking at using Sola cam or
devran all or cerflan for grass weeds so
annual grasses now one other thing I'll
mention is for new plantings
devran all is probably the safest
material it can be used on root pieces
it can be used on tissue culture plants
so if something for the first year
devran or maybe the better of the grass
choices in the case of the broadleaf
materials sin bar really is not a good
option during the transplant year and if
you use any prints up it really should
be at a half rate and I'm not really
crazy about using prints up the first
year until maybe the first fall of
making maybe a half rate application the
first year and that is in our
recommendations that are listed is that
you can find online with the UMass
website in the New England small fruit
pest pest management guide Kassar on I
didn't say a whole lot about Katherine
is not really a replacement for prints
up or sin bar what Katherine is is a
soil applied material that can do a good
job of controlling a wide range of
perennial species and the reason I want
to spend just a minute or so on
Katherine it's because unlike these
other crops that have a lot of mark
where you can use roundup in the fall
and you have bark there and the crop is
protected you need to be really careful
in raspberries because just like the
weeds will have a better chance of dying
in the fall if you get round up on your
raspberry crop there's also a lot of
translocation going on at that time of
the year for the crop so the time that
you can you could provide the biggest
danger to your raspberry crop while your
bramble crop in general is gonna be with
a fall application of Roundup so if you
just have a few perennial weeds here in
their spot treatments make a lot of
sense but if you've got a lot of
perennial weeds maybe you've already got
the crop planted you forgot about
perennial weeds during the fallow year
or time has gone by you've got a lot of
printing weeds present maybe you should
think about using Katherine Katherine
comes as a wet about powder
also comes as a granular formulation if
you're going after perennial weeds the
granular formulation makes the most
sense
the wettable powder material does not
work as well as the granules the key
about cast iron application is the
probably the best timing would be very
late fall early winter before the ground
freezes and just before the first
snowfall you want to get this material
on when the ground when it's weather is
cold above 50 degrees is not good it
will volatilize so even this time of
year if we have a little break in the
weather you can get out there maybe
there's no snow but there's a snowstorm
coming it still makes sense to put some
caster on some people wait a little bit
later but when we start getting to a
situation where you might have
temperatures 50 degrees or higher it's
probably too late to apply the caster on
and again we talked about some of these
post emergence materials roundup grill
marks on a rage for post emergence
control again grim accion and rage are
only contact materials roundup once we
get into the establishment year because
touchdown can no longer be used is used
for perennials now that the spot
treatment I mentioned before is
something you won't find in their
recommendations but I wanted to mention
it real quick there was a time when you
could buy a little clipper one of them
was called clip clean both with a kk li
p KL een and if you google that you
might find some other products that are
out there and what these are are ways to
apply a small amount of Roundup onto the
blade of your clipper but it can also be
done by hand so we're talking about
using a handheld clipper you cannot use
straight round up because it's too thick
you need two parts water one part
roundup you basically would dip the
blade of your hand Clippers into the
solution and make a cut near the base of
the perennial weed now what makes this
the good part about this let me tell you
about the bad part first the bad part is
it's obviously very labor-intensive
because you're going to go out there and
you're going to cut every one of these
weeds the good part is is it doesn't
make any difference what time of year
you do it unlike a foliar application of
roundup which is really only gonna work
late summer or fall to get the
translocation
an application with a clipper in this
manner will work at any time of the year
so if you have a vining perennial for
example that's growing up into your
planting you can go out there in the
spring when it's 3 or 4 inches high
before it ever grows into the planting
and you can make some cuts and maybe you
take a roll this week or this month and
another row next month but over the
course of the growing season you can go
after it just about any time that the
weeds are growing so it has potential
for spot treatment of perennial weeds
without making an application with a
sprayer without potentially contacting
the crop and causing problems but
something that is highly effective so
just something to consider so again
here's the list as we mentioned and
again soil applied post emergence grass
materials broadleaf materials and
hopefully after I went through the
explanation that entire list makes a
little bit more sense about how things
fit in so some final thoughts
nowyou weed problems mulch effectively
when you can do it maintain the Middle's
as David as mentioned if you're using
herbicides apply them at the right time
at the right rates and with the right
equipment to avoid crop injury and to
maximize control I believe that using
residual materials makes more sense than
post emergence materials in brambles for
the most part rotate' chemistry's means
that if you use one product this year
for broadleaf material or control use a
different product next year if you're
using a grass material and you surf land
this year use devran all next year try
not to use the same materials over and
over and again and please read and
follow all label directions don't forget
about the worker protection standards
they apply to all growers they apply to
conventional materials they apply to
organic materials we even follow all the
label directions follow the work
protection standards and keep yourself
your family and employees safe that's
all I have
job of giving us an overview of each
cultural and chemical we control out
options I think it's probably one of the
best comprehensive presentations on weed
control for bramble crops that I've ever
been at I also want to just say one
thing and maybe rich you could answer
this I do not have gallery touchdown or
rage in our 2010 guidelines and I just
attempted to try to check that you don't
happen to know whether those are
registered in New York do you
I believe touchdown is touchdown is
actually hopefully the lawyers won't
here this is exactly the same thing as
roundup different company but it only it
only has a non barring label and but
it's exactly the same product you could
certainly use roundup in the in the
transplant year if you don't have if you
don't have touchdown registered rage is
brand new it is possible that your DQ
has not approved it yet in in New York
State it's I believe this is the first
year we just put it into our our new
guide which will be coming out in 2010
and gallery has been around for a while
as I mentioned it's a nursery material
but it is possible that New York has
never registered one of the reasons some
people might not have put it in all
their recommendations is it's quite
expensive and for that reason alone it
might not be in your guide but it is
worth checking for New York State so for
those of you who are from New York State
we'll try to make
if any of these are actually legal
unable to be used when try to put that
on the Cornell berry website and I think
the banana to let us know about them so
I'm hoping that we have some folks who
have questions we're going to move into
the final phase but now is your chance
to ask anything that's on your mind or
they might want to know about we control
for bramble crops very quiet group I'm
hoping that you can actually hear us I'm
sure you would let us know if you
couldn't
I just put the last the page up here
that has the handouts and other
information about we control for bramble
crops that you can download I have one
more poll well we've got a few people
typing some things that's great
so let's see what they say I'll open up
this other poll just to get some ideas
about whether or not people had some
challenges with the webinar this time
Jeff asked about any experience with
wipers so let me let me address let me
address that so a wiper application is
similar it's sort of a cross between
making a spray or using the Clippers in
terms of effectiveness it will work the
same as a spray will work it does not
have the benefit of the clipping which
he'll give you the quick translocation
but certainly any of these wipers that
make these little little ones that are
like hockey sticks with the nylon rope
just remember just as I mentioned before
about the Clippers you cannot use
straight roundup in there and you have
to use some water because the roundup is
too thick it will not flow through that
nylon rope but it will give you the same
effect as if you are making a foliar
application and again because it's
similar to a foliar application fall is
the best time
there are many generic glyphosate labels
out there as eric has mentioned I have
not seen the labels of all of the
generic glyphosate products because of
course roundup is is about is more than
15 or 17 years old now so it is off
patent I believe that many of the
companies especially when they're
gearing towards vegetable and fruit
growers have tried to make the labels
very similar but of course if you buy
any of the generic glyphosate products
make sure that these crops are actually
listed on those those labels
all right we've got one other person
typing I'm not sure if he's typing to
the group I did want to let you know if
you do type your question into the whole
group it will be recorded for during the
archive recording so everyone will be
able to see it later and that's helpful
and most a lot of people have voted but
I do want to thank both of our speakers
a few more seconds and see if this
question is coming thank you our
speakers for joining us today I also
want to thank all of you attendees we
had some challenges at least on my end
we had some video and audio challenges
but it doesn't look like it was too bad
for folks but I appreciate you hanging
in there with us in case you did lose
audio it did come back and
I guess that question was not for the
group but anyway so I guess there's no
more questions coming and I just want to
thank you I will leave this webpage open
so that those of you who would like to
continue trying to download handouts can
do that for a few more minutes and
I guess that's it thank you so much dr.
Bonanno and dr. handly for being with us
thanks the rest of you and hopefully
we'll see you for the next ferry webinar
it's the bramble disease management
webinar on February 3rd at 1 o'clock in
the afternoon and don't hesitate to give
me a call or send me an email if you
have some questions about running the
webinars or registering for them alright
thank you everybody thank you so much
you
you